[Music]
alana is with us in chicago hi alana how
are you
hey i'm good how are you better than i
deserve what's up
so i just graduated college in may and i
worked multiple jobs throughout college
so i'm actually in a position where
i can pay off all of my student loans
but i'm
just kind of stuck because the loans are
in deferment through january so
i would like to get into investing but
obviously that's borrowed money that's
allocated for my loans
but i'm just kind of curious what you
think i should do in the meantime
between now and january
um well i have this money
so you're saying you have the money in
cash to pay off all of your student
loans today
yeah
well that's a great place to be uh i
like that a lot and you're saying should
i hold off in order to start investing
well i'm wondering if i should put
if i don't know if it's smart to put a
portion of that while i have cash into
investing or
pay off my debt and then you know
then consider investing yeah well we we
teach the baby steps and this is the
plan that works and a lot of people want
to do them out of order and i think
you're wanting to make the right
decision here with your money and i know
january's going to come and you're like
should i just wait and pay it off then
but here's the thing
if you follow the baby steps we teach
that you pay off all of your debt in
baby step two using the debt snowball
and is this all your all your debt just
the student loans
okay so you could be done with baby step
two today
uh which then you'd move on to baby step
three building your your fully funded
emergency fund which i like as you head
out into your adult life now that you've
graduated and so i want you to pay off
that debt as soon as possible and if you
have the cash to do that today well
you're going to have plenty of time to
invest you just graduated you're going
to be a multi-millionaire if you follow
these steps so i'm not as worried about
investing as i am about this debt that's
hanging over your life right now and i
don't want you to wait on the government
i don't want you to wait on anyone when
you can take control and you have the
cash in your bank today alana how old
are you
22. excellent what's your degree in
uh packaging science
say again
packaging science wow packaging science
did i hear that right
fascinating
okay so have you got have you landed a
job
yeah i started in june so i've been
working for a few months now great what
do you make
uh 70. well done
amazing job that's a great job coming
out of 22. you really got a really good
start
okay here's the trick
inside of every one of us it is human
nature to want a shortcut
with money you need to fight
that beast
that says you can do a shortcut
there is no good shortcuts with money
it's common sense
it's a slog it's a grind
and you become wealthy
if you try to do shortcuts you get
setbacks
shortcuts equal setbacks
and that that beast that looks for
shortcuts that's the one that's asking
the question down inside of you and
that's just normal you're not doing
anything wrong
okay it's just normal to ask that
question is there something some way i
should try to move these shells and hide
the p
but no matter how many times you move
those shells that stinking student loan
is still laying there
unless you just write a check and pay it
off you got it
so the cleanliness the cleanliness of
your life
the risk lowered you make 70 000 you
don't have a debt in the world now you
can really be a rock star investor you
can really start filling up that 401k
that roth ira starts saving for a house
start doing some other stuff because you
got no black cloud hanging over your
head so here's the instruction listen
carefully
pay the student loan off
today
before the close of business
when you hang up the phone pay off the
student loan okay
absolutely can i ask a follow-up
question really quick
is it wise to then after that's paid off
to
max out my retirement
i would put it at 15
of your income
and then i would start saving for a
house above that and make sure you have
an emergency fund of three to six months
of expenses you're gonna have some money
left over after you pay off the student
loan
yeah okay how much
uh about five grand good okay before you
start your retirement let's build that
up to a full rainy day fund three to six
months of expenses so probably want that
to be about 15 grand so if you have
fifteen thousand dollars cash that you
never touch for anything except big time
emergencies
and you have no debt
you are in the driver's seat to rock and
roll
then you start putting fifteen percent
of your income into retirement and i'm
thinking you're probably a millionaire
by 35.
that's if you do this okay that that's
where i think you're headed so you hold
on i want to help you do it because i
want to hear your story when you're 35
i'm still going to be here doing this so
um i'm going to send you a copy of the
book the total money makeover and show
you exactly what georgia's talking about
those baby steps things
and exactly how to do them and exactly
why to do them and uh because i think
you're actually going to do this it
sounds like in your voice she's you're
actually going to do it sometimes we
give people advice and they're like yeah
yeah yeah yeah and we can tell they're
not going to do it so but you you're
actually going to go do this and then if
you follow all the way through you
really are going to be a millionaire
you really are because if you're making
70 at 22 you're gonna be making 150 at
27.
this is where you're headed
because people that think as clearly as
you think that's what they do you've
done a very good job setting your life
up i'm so proud of you hold on kelly
i'll pick up and we're going to give you
a copy of the total money makeover
there's hope george
there's 22 year olds out there like her
there is hope for our future america
i love it i'm just shocked they're
everywhere and she has the money we get
to talk to them all the time they're
everywhere
god if we just have people that's smart
in congress
i mean what would we do uh if you just
have people you have to be like and they
could take construction like she can
yeah because there's nobody in congress
can take instruction you never got a
call from a congressman or woman yet
[Laughter]
i'd pay good money to hear that call
we'll make it happen before you believe
they were trying to get me to endorse
them but that was all
oh jeez
keep dreaming she's awesome what a great
young lady inspiring uh man i'm telling
you i get to talk these 20-somethings
all the time like this gives me a lot of
hope no wonder you've got a positive
outlook that's it that's it